why is he the wrong person to piss off
on your way up who was he he is
incredibly powerful he ended up being
the president of the sulk institute
what does that mean to the average
person that's listening to this
he was i think the head of the national
he was certainly the editor of the
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences he was the editor-in-chief of
the main oncology journal
he is
the science
the way science is played in the united
states is hardball full-on
okay
and there are cabals associations of
scientists and their former postdocs
and they operate as units
okay they're competitive units
and ender was sitting at the top of an
amazingly powerful stack
in large part because his mentor was
david baltimore who got the nobel prize
for reverse transcriptase was seminal
in setting up the regulations for
recombinant dna former head of caltech
you know left the salk went to mit ended
up head of an institute at mit before he
went to caltech and there was a huge
scandal around him
in terms of his ethics
inder was the postdoc that characterized
reverse transcriptase for david
baltimore
inder was i think a full professor at
the age of 30. he was fast-tracked
incredibly powerful
um controlled a very large amount of
money incredible guy
incredible
he he
science
for me
science is science you know whether
whether you're powerful or i'm powerful
or tony fauci is powerful one of the
things i love about it is it's an
environment of ideas
and
you know if if i say something in a
scientific forum
and a young graduate student pops up in
the audience and has a argument
that demonstrates that my interpretation
of the data is wrong
that person will be heard
and i will change my opinion
that's the fundamental nature that's why
science has to have this dynamic i
actually agree with you we need that
discourse and the debate because
for me
the hardest thing for the average person
you talk to is who do you trust so if
you can flip back on your on your search
engine and go to the next science
article
bingo salk institute professor so that's
not a science the science version that's
a san diego version resigns after
investigation yes so
um
inder had
a long history of abuse why did you
leave that article go back to that
article
resigns after investigation go to san
diego union he's an incredibly powerful
person and this is typical of these
super powerful scientists as they can do
no wrong
because the indirect
money indirect cost money that they
generate supports their institute
in modern academia
these institutes and universities are
supported by the indirect costs at
harvard for every dollar if you get a
federal grant or contract for every
dollar that you get to spend on your
research
something like a dollar ten goes to the
university
for every dollar
you get to spend a dollar ten goes to
your dean in the university okay okay so
you're generating as as as a faculty
member yeah you're a revenue a major
revenue source that supports the
university this is all built into the
structure of nih part of the nih mission
is to support american medical colleges
so did he ever lose his license did he
he's not an md he's not an md okay he's
a phd he's a phd so
he resigns after investigation in what
is this sexual allegations type of thing
but it's only part of how he operated he
he was incredibly powerful and grossly
unethical
um
maybe tell me this because you know a
lot of times you will learn
if you're if you're if you're
editor-in-chief of proceedings of
national academy of sciences in the
major arc
oncology journal
everybody has to be nice to you ender
did stuff
routinely let me tell you a story okay
i'm a graduate student okay and and i
spoke to a postdoc in the lab at the
same time who had exactly the same
experience
so i'm a graduate student i'm working in
this laboratory i'm the only graduate
student it's an intensely competitive
environment the way he runs his lab is
he would have multiple postdocs all
assigned on the same topic and they
would compete with each other within the
laboratory
okay so that's one strategy that these
big big scientists use
so
um
when i was in the lab
inder came to me with a stack of
people's grant applications these are
supposed to be confidential
and he gave him to me and he said
read these and get ideas
so i i
i was shocked
because this is how old are you at that
time
um 27. he said read these and get ideas
right other people's grants okay you're
supposed to be confident let me ask you
is that a traditional
uh exercise that many people were doing
at that time or that's i don't know
about anybody else but that is grossly
in inappropriate illegal unethical
grossly unethical i ask that because i
don't know your world grants grants and
grant proposals and contract proposals
are supposed to be strictly confidential
when they're sent out to the reviewers
and these days the nih will actually put
you in jail if you do this
okay
so he asks you to look at these and come
up with ideas to to get ideas from other
people's submissions you're 27 years old
at the time okay so i go to um
the head the functional science head of
the salk institute
and i say
this has happened what am i supposed to
do about this
and he said
maybe inder isn't the best mentor for
you who said that to you
um this i'm blanking on his name it's
not tony hunter there's an it was
another lead scientist in the molecular
biology and virology laboratories okay
okay so this is the environment where
this kind of thing is tolerated in
addition
in ender's lab there's this long history
of sexual harassment by him
in you know in the dark room with women
etc etc
um eventually it caught up with him but
for a long time i'm told that the way
the saul handled this because there were
multiple claims
um is that if you were a woman
and you wanted to work in his laboratory
you felt like you needed to as a postdoc
or whatever
you had to sign a disclaimer with the
salk institute that you would not sue
them if he did any of these actions to
you that's how it was handled is that
known is that known amongst people that
worked there yes okay
now who would you say were some of his
allies names like would you is he an
ally with fauci is he a friend of a
fouch i don't know what his relationship
is with tony his main power structure
runs through the david baltimore network
got it
got it okay so what was the following
with the two of you what was there a
obvious falling out or was it just like
subtle that we're going to go our
separate ways no it was really i mean i
ended up with a nervous breakdown over
what happened
i i had a formal diagnosis of
post-traumatic stress disorder when i
took my master's degree and left i took
a master's in a little of a phd
okay there was a cascade of events
um
in in for me you got it to go back in
time i'm this cocky
arrogant
believe in myself been out of this come
out of this high pressure environment
where i'm rigorously trained i'm able to
withstand scrutiny and and go toe-to-toe
with the best
and have been now
but i'm i'm in my 20s and um
so
i own those character flaws and i
compensate for them now it's part of why
i am the way i am that i went through
that transition
um but i own what i was then um i would
challenge anybody i would challenge
injure
in publicly or privately both okay
because that's the nature of science
sure okay
um or i thought it was sure
uh
i mean to set the framework i think
there was six or seven nobel laureates
at the salk at the time in addition to
jonas salk it was the pinnacle of
molecular virology in the world
arguably
um and i was working for the top gene
therapy expert retroviral gene therapy
expert which is what i wanted to make my
career
when i the laboratory when i was there
included um a guy named dinko valerio
who is pioneering a whole new technology
for gene therapy
using recombinant dna virus called
adenovirus okay dinko left the lab
founded a company called crucel
because of my ideas he came to me once
and he said after we both left the lab
i'm setting the stage not bragging on
myself okay
um this was a period of intense
intellectual foment
um i had come up with these ideas about
using gene therapy technology for
vaccines
dinko created this company crew cell
acquired this cell line called persev6
which is of fetal origin
tried to develop the platform for gene
therapy purposes and came to meet a
conference a few years after we both
left ender's lab and said robert you're
right
the best application for this technology
is for vaccines and i'm going to change
the focus of crew cell to become a
vaccine company instead of a gene
therapy company
crew cell was later sold for what was
considered to be a huge amount of money
at the time to a company called johnson
johnson
that is the technology that is in the j
j vaccine that is why the j j vaccine
technology exists it goes back to that
same laboratory in that same time frame
it was an intense period
of innovation
but inder had this weakness
um he talk about arrogant
um
a cascade of events happen that i've
spoken about for hours and hours on
other podcasts and you can look on our
website and you can see my wife's first
person accounting with all the documents
et cetera so no reason to go over the
cascade of things that happened that led
to the inventions and the discoveries no
i'm more curious to know what was it a
a a public falling out where afterwards
just hear me out yeah okay
um
so
i filed invention disclosures had mark
kindy the postdoc in the lab working
next to me cross sign them
for this stuff
and filed them with the salk institute
i'd been trained in what one had to do
to protect intellectual property
okay
so
file them with the salk institute
this i had an interview with assault
lawyers they made a determination that i
was the sole inventor
meanwhile the head of the salk institute
de hoffman
who later died of aids from a blood
transfusion
he i think he worked on the manhattan
project he was a big shot
okay he was the head of the sulk
institute the salk had created an
organization i think it's called sybia
salk institute biologic associates i
think was the acronym
and it was intended to be their
for-profit arm of their not-for-profit
salk institute so that it would generate
revenue so that they could become
independent of the nih for funding
or less dependent
okay so they were hoping that all this
massive amount of intellectual property
they were creating would go to this
for-profit company generate revenue so
that the professors didn't have to write
grants and contracts all the time
and so de hoffman calls ender in
and
calls me into the office
on short notice
and says what is this about you setting
up a collaboration with syntax
because centex had been the source of
the canonic lipids consequent to tony
hunter another senior salk faculty
member
it's a brilliant mind still there okay
tony had advised me to get in touch with
these people at centex
to access this new emerging technology i
think because he reviewed the paper it
wasn't published yet
he said robert you need to get in touch
with syntax to test their new lipid
technology
that is what led to the fundamental
final invention that enabled all of this
and i had set up a collaboration
agreement with indus full knowledge
with syntax in order to get them to
transfer these canonical lipids into the
salt so that i could use them as
intellectual property and and
composition of matter transfer
de hoffman heard about all this because
he heard about the invention disclosure
and he called in during and then i got
called in and i got asked what was the
story what happened here
and ender was being attacked for having
established this illicit collaboration
with syntax
and um inder denied knowing anything
about it said that i was a sole actor in
this he had no knowledge of this he
didn't know what i was doing
i had just done this independently
um i was blown away
i thought in good faith i was coming
into this really high level person
to disclose
the chain of events and in fact what i
hadn't realized is i was coming in to an
environment where indoor was being
called on the carpet for doing something
that was
expressly forbidden by the new policy at
the sulk because it would result in an
intellectual entanglement intellectual
property entanglement with this
for-profit company called syntax in palo
alto
and so indoor denied knowing anything
about it i was stunned
you know remember i'm i'm
i'm not even 30 years old
i'm i'm believe i believe in science
right
um and i've just encountered big science
for the first time good and hard yeah
okay not for the first time i mean i cut
my teeth at the laboratory in davis that
made the first discovery of a retrovirus
being involved in any immunodeficiency
syndrome and primates no no i'm talking
about you're coming across for the first
time the manipulative side of science
like this
okay
and so i go to i went in this one i went
to tony hunter
and i said tony
interest said this i can't believe it
and he said to me
robert of course ender lied what did you
expect him to do
and that was a you're no longer in
kansas moment
for me
but
is that how it ended no indoor had it so
then
there became this whole long thread i
worked with assault lawyers we wrote a
patent based on what i had done
and what i disclosed sure and the
potential applications for it and then
there was a series of papers that made
everybody realize that i'd stumbled onto
something big
was this serendipitous series of events
where i was teaching an emerald tain
teaching associate
an embryology course where i was
preparing embryos we would call them
frog
tadpoles sure um and chick embryos and i
decided to take the technology that i've
been working on and see if it will work
in these whole animals and it did to my
great surprise and
that was the trip wire that set this
whole cascade in motion because that was
the origin
of in vivo non-viral delivery everybody
suddenly realized that this was a
fundamental change and the university of
california
and the professor at um
the university of california that was
the professor teaching the embryology
course that i was working under her
name's christine holt um she was a
fellow still training not a real faculty
member
she insisted that she should be on the
patent she should be an inventor
ender insisted that he should be an
inventor even though the salk institute
said in their initial assessment that he
wasn't a co-inventor and he denied
knowing anything about it to the hofstra
so long story short just for the sake of
time because i got a lot of other things
that i want to go through with you just
is it fair to say that the whole
dispute was over here's a young guy that
comes in you
you stumble upon something that is
absolutely ridiculous that can help a
lot of people out transformational and
then and then and then everybody wants
to take credit for it and control it
because there's a potential huge it
happens all the time huge gold rush
which by the way that happens all the
time not only
where you know the whole story with uh
tesla not the car tesla but tesla edison
you know that whole story things like
that this has historically happened many
times
do you remember that one movie called
the genius uh what is that one movie
uh uh kai where the guy creates the
windshield wiper and ford tries to
assume and they say we came up with it
it's a very good movie those types of
stories are everywhere so i've i've
experienced this kind of behavior all
through my career so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]